en janvier ils seront à las vegas l'un
est basé à montigny le bretonneux
le second est originaire de rambouillet
lamberth renora et petits mots dits le
kent sont les lauréats du challenge par
les sags les crs grâce à la réinvention
le giro livre c'est une nouvelle forme
de mobilité
c'est un nouveau type de fauteuil
roulant s'est basé sur un gyropode donc
c'est on connaît de marque segway par
exemple donc c'est une plateforme sur
deux roues et contrôler avec 60 de
gravité non là on l'adapté pour laurent
universel pour permettre à des personnes
à mobilité réduite de se dépasser aussi
bien assis que debout c'est un chargeur
sans fil
donc c'est un pad qui econnaît geek est
branché sur secteur et sur lequel on
peut recharger tous ces appareils
simultanément on peut charger 4 à 5 ces
appareils simplement les équipements
d'un petit autocollant et on les posant
sur ce pad avec six autres candidats ils
ont eu sept minutes pour convaincre le
jury et le public
ce sont des entreprises qui ont moins de
8 ans à l'origine du concours la chambre
de commerce et d'industrie versailles
yvelines
le service las vegas si le regroupement
de deux très grands salons sans
l'automobile salon d'électronique de
différents types de salon de la
communication donc ce sont des gens ce
sont des gens qui vont pouvoir accéder à
cette immensité à ce salon immense dans
un environnement où avant tout l'intérêt
c'est le business c'est à dire votre
giraud lift m'intéresse je sais moi
d'ores et déjà que je peux vous en
commander temps parce que j relifté
énergie square poseront leurs valises
aux états unis le 9 janvier prochain
la cci les a nommés experts las vegas de
la communauté open innove
[Applaudissements]